hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreign any new event has
just went live we have all the info
about it so definitely stay tuned for
this video because I'll keep you guys
all today what's what's happening even a
for honor documentary and everything
that has to do with this event so as
always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I covered the
informational side of foreigner that
being found strange this hero updates
patch notes leaks so we do want to be
filled up today with everything
happening in the world of foreigner
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
my discord will be in the description if
you want to check that out when that
let's get started so first up to get the
random thing out of the way real quick
playing hard is a documentary actually
about for honor I believe that's the
title and it was it's gonna be shown at
some type of event in the next couple of
days but it will be on Netflix as of
about next week I think it's Wednesday
so that's extremely cool definitely
gonna be watching it's about the whole
process of foreigner how it came out
and what the whole process was so I'm
very excited actually watch this I
actually have a reason to watch
something on Netflix now but now for the
good news we have the whole event and
the new event is gonna be called black
priors were passed it's a huge lore
event dedicated to black prior in its
origin story I have a slight feeling
because we're going to be having events
every single season throughout this
entire year I have a feeling that each
of these seasons are gonna be dedicated
to the lore of the characters throughout
the year of the Harbinger so next season
when we get I believe the samurai hero
we're gonna be getting an event
dedicated to lore about him so we'll
have to see how that goes but as usual
we have lots of stuff with this event
and this is a picture of the map like
seasons ago I think season 5 they wrote
the story of the lore of or dagger based
off the CEO little yellow spot
surrounded by all the other factions in
the actual faction war that we
participated as seen in the top left
season five I think battle 26 or
something like that the Knights actually
had that point on the map and was
surrounded by all the factions and we
never lost that zone eventually like the
next battle over we actually kept
overtaking them so they based the lore
and the trailer of how the Vikings were
over running and then Vorta Kirk a min
and just killed everyone in that it's
actually a lake on that specific spot so
that's why they decided to do stuff with
Harbor so though I have a feeling
they're gonna be adding more lords of
the characters based off of our actions
that we do in the faction war and many
other things so I can't wait to see what
they do for past seasons but the weekly
quest in arcade is going to be called
crimson offensive and like I said this
is based off of the lore so every single
this game is going to be about Vikings
and you're gonna be fighting I believe
only in harbor though it could be wrong
but there's also a new background and
it's a blood red sky with the barren
no-man's land of sorts looks really sick
next is the soldiers the in the order it
goes Knights samurai and Vikings from
left to right easily one of the best
I've ever seen super creepy and really
scary which stuff we fits the theme of
this event I think my personal favorite
is the samurai I don't know why maybe
it's cuz you just can't see through that
mascot that but that could just be me
next up we have the special game mode
and it says in the top left battle of
attrition I don't actually know if this
is the correct game mode name I'd have
to check the event tab but we're just
gonna go based off that that is the
actual game mode name so but take that
with a grain of salt I'm not actually
sure but it is a 4v4 PvP game mode on
harbor in its standard Dominion with a
little bit of a twist
defenders must have win by defeating
players and minions and the attackers
must win by conquering zones you can
also capture the center lanes for both
points to earn more points for both
teams so it's a fair for every single
team so it's a little bit of a Dominion
and a breach hybrid on screen is harbor
in a small example that they shows in
the PowerPoint the first wave of minions
go to the two corner objective which
would be a and C depending on you know
for playing Dominion and then the next
wave of minions would go to B as if it
was normal Dominion all the minions
would only flow to B and we would have
to go to the a flag and the C flood
capture it now that'd break off if the
attackers get a point they will get 500
points and they will stay like that
so the defenders have to make sure to
hold all the points as much as possible
because two captures equals 1000 points
which means the defenders are breaking
instantly I don't actually like that you
get 500 points because it's almost like
a guarantee that you're gonna be 500 to
0 because the defenders don't get points
for capturing objectives they only get
points for capturing the middle and the
attackers guarantee get a guaranteed 500
points and right off the start because
the minions capturing the corner 1 so I
don't really know how they're gonna do
it this I'd have to see the game-mode
for myself and play it because
personally I haven't even hopped on yet
my game is still updating but I hope
that is isn't as overpowered as I think
it would be for the attacker side next
up we have the weapons and if you've
been on this channel for a long time we
always show the weapons in groups of 4
so it always goes top left top right
bottom left and bottom right so in that
order the first 4 weapons we have are
our remove beserker black prior for the
first time ever Centurion and then
second group is conquer
gladiator Highlander and JJ Kent's a la
bringer Nobu she and Nisha are third
Orochi peacekeeper Raider and shaman are
4th Shaolin shinobi shougo ki and T on D
and then lastly finishing it with
valkyrie warden and warlord so this is
the first time black pyre actually has a
new weapon as an event disease of course
recently released in season 9 that's
worth exciting to hear I like the theme
that they're going here it's not like
really flashy gold colours it's more
grays and a lot of symbolic stuff
throughout the weapons so let me know
your thoughts on these weapons I think
they're pretty cool but we also have
cosmetics there's a new in-game event
effect called verdigris dark oath this
will be available in an emo execution
and idol form and you can get this in
arcade in all game modes so this is the
lootable type of content that we can get
there's also a new outfit called war
daggers or pasta for all heroes in every
game mode in arcade once again more
vulnerable stuff and new ornaments for
each faction that actually changes
depending on your color swatch really
big fan of the samurai and the Wulin
outfit and this adds of course to even
more stuff that we can get and this adds
the more stuff that we can get in terms
of loot that we have to get throughout
the game and grinding not just buying
with our steel but don't worry I will be
covering all of that in a future video
on how to get the XP and how to get the
loot the most in any game mode arcade
and without arcade so trust me either
tonight or tomorrow morning I will
definitely have a video about that as
quick as I can
so promise me that but we get even more
stuff and we're not even done yet we get
new embossing x' which are part of the
new bird outfits which I'll talk about
in a second when you get the outfit
these embossing come with it there's
even a new emote called verdigris ascent
your character goes down and levitates a
ball that then explodes really sick and
you can buy a bundle which that's the
bird outfit ornaments emo battle outfit
and effect for every single hero for
30,000 steal so if you do not want to
buy and you don't want to grind all your
stuff it is available from March 14th to
April 1st but if you don't want to grind
you know I'm gonna have time you can
easily buy it for your hero and this is
one of those where you don't have to pay
double for the same thing so say for
example I already bought the bird outfit
for my hero instead of it being 30k the
price will decrease because they don't
want you paying double for the same
thing so the more stuff that you get you
would it would you essentially have to
pay less for the bundle so I like to do
as I like to grind constantly for the
next
weeks and then right before hits April
1st or the day before I'll then buy it
if I don't have it as to not waste a lot
of Steel and actually get some playtime
but the reason I wanted to save the bird
outfit is because the video is extremely
long but these are the new bird outfits
these are now in the mask tab or what's
called illustrious tab they're now
twenty thousand steel very similar to a
mask outfit the Knights have an eagle
the Vikings will have a raven the
samurai get a snow owl and the woolen
get a vermilion it's not a Phoenix I
promise you the dev said it was a
vermilion so I'm going with them and
these are actually really cool the birds
will fly around you when you do
executions they'll hover on your
shoulder come behind you and doing an
emo stuff like that so I'm excited to
get picked this one up I probably will
get the wool in one just because I like
the Vermillion look not really a big fan
of the Knights one but I mean it's a new
thing so I might as well get it in
anyway but let me know your guys think
about that
and that guys is gonna wrap up the
entire video like I said we have we
covered a lot of stuff we covered the
new outfits the new emotes everything
with this whole new event so definitely
go hop on now by the time this video
should be live it the event should
actually be up or at least be able to
update so definitely go check that out
there was a bug with a lot of people
where they if they played the if they
tried to play the event before it came
out their whole stats would get reset I
saw a couple people messaging me about
that I believe that is not a permanent
thing I think it's just because they
were doing a maintenance so definitely
try to hop on and just one last tidbit
of information like I said I will try to
have the how to get the fat how to get
the loop fast this like I've done for
every single event prior to this I'll
try to have that video out as soon as I
can
because I have to go into the game and
figure out which ones I lootable which
ones or not and then I'll make the video
so I promise you I'll have it try I'll
try to get it up the next couple days
with that like TV if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational site or foreigner that
being balanced changes hero updates
patch notes and leaks they're going to
be kept up today with everything
happening in the world of foreigner
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
and with that my two most recent videos
will be on screen if you guys want to
check that out the guy said we've girls
today thank you for watching the video
and peace out enjoy the event
[Music]
you
[Music]